nate thank you very much so we are all
sort of adjusting to these higher
temperatures here in the valley before
the real heat of the summer kicks in
you know so are plants and veggies
they're adjusting to the heat too
there are some ways to protect your
garden though in the heat for example
water your plants in the morning try and
be consistent been consistent about when
you water them every day
plants you might not think need much
water they're going to need more in
these triple digit temperatures
if you have a landscaped yard not a lot
of us have that in
southern nevada but if you do keep an
eye on larger plants and trees
i'd be paying attention to the bigger
more structural plants
first trees and shrubs that would be
much harder for me to replace and and
mean a lot more to the landscape and
providing shade for other plants as well
if you can stick with a daily watering
schedule with your plants and only add
more if you can tell the soil is dry we
know how much
watering is a concern here in southern
nevada so be smart if you can